dicen de él que fue el único personaje
verdaderamente indispensable de la
revolución cubana raúl castro- fue
durante casi 50 años el prototipo del
protagonista secundario a la sombra de
su hermano fidel carismático y
personalista raúl tenía los atributos
del escudero era el comunista
verdaderamente convencido con una
formación intelectual sólida y una gran
disciplina prudente y ausente de la
esfera pública la presidencia le llegó
de forma interina en 2006 y
definitivamente en 2008 ocupando la
durante 10 años
a mí no me dieron
y aun raúl aseguraba que el 90 por
ciento de su tiempo estaba dedicado al
partido comunista participó junto a su
hermano en el asalto del 23 de julio de
1953 del cuartel moncada paso por la
cárcel y el exilio fue expedicionario
del granma y guerrillero en sierra
maestra creó las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias además de ser el
responsable de las relaciones con la
unión soviética pero también fue según
los opositores raúl el terrible el
encargado de la persecución de
disidentes y homosexuales un
calificativo que para muchos vivido en
raúl el compasivo tras su ascenso a la
presidencia con una actitud más
tolerante reformadora y de apertura
llegando a normalizar durante su
gobierno relaciones con eeuu reiteró
nuestra disposición a convivir
civilizadamente
[Música]
en 1973 en un discurso raúl dijo que a
los dirigentes históricos de la
revolución el tiempo también les pasa
inexorablemente por lo que siempre han
estado preparando su legado fue reelecto
en 2013 pero el régimen quedó en manos
de miguel díaz canel en 2018 y el paso a
la sombra mientras dedicaba el tiempo a
sus nietos a los libros y perseguía su
sueño de infancia criar gallos de pelea